les hits de l'été la suite en novembre
oui c'est
beau il fait encore beau qu'on a le
droit on est avec masque et le motif way
to keep its way à ses crochets
électro musique rock musique margot
c'est la suite du format des de l'été
que vous avez particulièrement appréciée
qui est sorti sur la chaîne ya déjà deux
ans mirador baba on s'en souvient c'est
une expérience de fou aujourd'hui on
fait la suite avec ces jeunes
compositeur à succès deux équipes ici
présente cette fois des trios nous
allons avoir trois jours pour composer
un sont nos deux sons seront en
concurrence à l'issue de ces trois jours
il ya le vote du jury et il ya le vote
des gens qui nous regardent on n'allait
pas juste refaire des hits de l'été
aujourd'hui on va faire des hits de
l'été des années 2000 années 2000 on
apprécie c'est assez incroyable beaucoup
de courant quand même dans les années
2000 énormément de courant comme tu as
eu l'électro un peu house roumaine
latine un peu tu as eu 113 tahure nbc
woerth en style libre à vous de choisir
le courant qui vous plaît le plus est un
vert un truc dans cette vague là on
n'aura pas forcément la même vibe en
plus les uns les autres j'ai peut-être
une idée de quelqu'un vous allez faire
vous avez peut-être une idée de quel
courant va faire qu'on se connaît un peu
tous ans et qui fuit effarant quoi mais
attention les surprises attention
attention
attention évidemment c'est de son valet
clip et et il faudra du coup faire des
clips cette fois en mode années 2000
passer de la frappe et ensuite on sera
jugé par les gens alors la dernière fois
le gagnant était un peu voilà désigné
par les vues des clips et les stream et
c'est cette année notion sortir en
format physique mais en format physique
le même que celui des années 2000 les
singles sortait dans une petite pochette
cartonnée moi j'aimerais celui de laurie
j'avais ma meilleure amie de laurine
jamais chihuahua lou bega chaque jour
lou bega 8 me soit jamais oui smith en
norvège écouter matt houston moi j'étais
plus xzibit à cette époque vous souvenez
les années 2000 c'était les ventes
physiques y avait pas de spotify deezer
n'y avait pas eu tu viens pas ne pas la
friche de quelle triste
sur étions en train de suggérer que des
gens achètent des stries à l'égard des
robots
toujours téléphone à
limiter sinon c'est faux ce fou
tous les bénéfices tirés des ventes des
physiques seront versés à une
association
ça me va le gagnant sera celui qui vend
le plus de physique comme dans les
années 2000 mais lambert a trop bien
mais surtout dans pile trois jours les
gars et ça passe très vite vous allez
voir c'est la fin de la compo vous avez
plus droit de toucher aux sons après ça
il doit être terminé vers liés que ce
soit la prod les paroles les tops live
tout doit être fini et puis ensuite on
passera devant le jury et ensuite on ira
tourné les clips qui sortiront plus tard
et ensuite on verra une fois que tout ça
sort qu'elle son gagne d'après les gens
je crois que j'ai tout dis oui je pense
aussi que tu as tout dit les gars quand
il est de ces canapés on est concurrent
pendant trois jours tous les coups sont
permis c'est parti et
est-ouest tout va bien non rien que sur
les claviers me jean et attendez vous
allez découvrir votre studio et oui vous
a préparé une petite pièce en studio
c'est un grand mot il ya 2-3 mousse
acoustique un bureau d enceinte une
carte son les gars c'est parti c'est
parti c'est parti à tout allez vous
partez sur quoi du coup
[Musique]
messieurs attention faith révèle de
crohn en exclusivité
est ce qu'on va faire un plan montre sur
le mythe qui a une rolex domino's pizza
c'est bon pour vous j'adore les
restaurants italiens il faut qu'on
prenne ce temps là il faut qu'on
trouvera très cher que l'ouvragé
gégène probable vas-y mid non belge en
est une autre j'en ai un autre mais
moi je vous dis il faut qu'on fasse la
fête pour compass madoff maintenant c
est ce qu on part sur un truc couper
décaler un peu où est ce qu'on la joue
la joueuse 113 coupé décalé façon ça ne
touchait pas autant que ça nous touche
aujourd'hui tu vas au bled ski +113
hausse mais sans classe était partout
sur la toile il était exportée en place
moi je dis revenez venu en parfait entre
comme ça tu vois jusqu au fond qu'un
truc comme ça c'est plus de quoi est ce
qu est ce que tu es capable ouais moi
c'est chaud non est ce que tu es capable
pas est ce que tu fous parce que je suis
chaud pour bhl un truc aussi un moyen
capable dans le quasiment tous les
styles
donc donc là propane est la suivante je
pense que ça peut être marrant de faire
un boys band faux produit d'une maison
disque en mode aux zones mais au greffe
best blend
je pense ça peut être pas mal de faire
un faux boys band comme ça au jour
chaque perso à cesson son caractère sa
manière de bouger sur le son du poussin
sont plutôt
déjà ce qui est sûr c'est que même si on
est trois mois je m'en bats les couilles
je vous
ferez vous obligez fringe et de son
essor de paille je le fais pas bien ce
que tu insinues way hattmatt l'auto tune
mais c'est vrai que avant qui est auto
tune et qu'on soit tous des combattants
ont chanté pour de vrai les enfants
voilà pour faire une bonne règle faut un
triangle il ya aux zones il ya le fait
de raconter n'importe quoi genre las
ketchup qui disent n'importe quoi dans
un morceau attend d'autres anecdotes
peut-être que les gens dont par le
refrain de las ketchup assez léger à
l'est les olé ça ne veut rien dire et on
prend un pays qui excite un peu les gens
soient le soleil pour l'espagne soit un
peu inconnu et très folklorique comme
l'europe de l'est ce troisième chose je
pense qu'il faut taper sur l'idée de
vision du futur qui avait dans les
années 2000 à une sorte de crazy frog
est une sorte de petit bonhomme en 3d ou
alors est-ce que c'est le futur
globalement avec des sons des synthés un
peu trop synthétiques bizarre qui est
censé l futuriste mais c'est un enfer je
pense que si on a ces trois là ça peut
être une bonne direction contre lyonnais
très belles choses et j'ai envie tu sens
bon français je l'avais coeur d'un
exposé moi aussi tout le monde est
d'accord avec ça parce qu'en fait il on
peut aussi faire un truc genre un peu
r'n'b mais j'ai l'impression qu'en face
c'est vraiment une team rapport à la
saison que je mets des emmerdes houblon
ils vont la faire ils vont le faire
mieux que nous donc non il faut qu'on
les démolisse sur un terrain qui l'a pas
fait tout ça est très confirmé ici je
sais pas ce que tu en course olivier
michaud qu'on commence n'écoute de basse
vas-y ça va donner goût ça a donné le
tempo
ça segura fais moi un peu de magie
[Musique]
vélos sont tout ça dans tous le sont je
sais que vous êtes des blagues mais ce
n'est pas une blague j'ai amené quelques
porte bonheur qui vont vraiment nous
aider
cette jeune diamant olano mais c'est
combien de cas c'est pas tout j'ai pas
ensuite j'ai ramené
c'est un saphir je transmets un cube de
cuivre c'est du vrai cuir ouais c'est
l'ouvrir et ça ça porte bonheur de mais
le diamant le diamant surtout le marché
font un truc tu as un truc un peu funky
cops
on ça c'est pas mal ça soit moi tiens ça
me rappelle ce cycle est historique
attention ça avons fait à temps
[Musique]
by antho comme ça
bloquée il faut le bloquer mais l'on
n'est peut-être
pas d'éclair ça c'est une petite pierre
montrez pas que ça nous ressemble et oui
là on parle pas trop mon
truc et
[Musique]
ça sonne classiques déjà et avec la
basse
ça ou pas moi ça me vois les gars les
gars bossent presque en fait il nous
parasites même pas qu'on bosse quand
même personnage en parlant de
parasitisme donnez moi un téléphone tu
veux faire quoi j'ai des amis qui
viennent de très loin et ça pourrait
être utile qu'ils aillent déranger
l'équipe adverse ils sont musiciens ok
c'est les mariachis
[Applaudissements]
je fais des accords plaqués
[Musique]
simple moins ça m'inspire tiens à lancer
les trous chanter sur le fait qu'il se
faisait recalé en boîte mais il était
dans la boîte c'est parce qu'un
petite ambiance c'est même des bruits
naturels un truc comme ça tu vois façon
partout j'ai vu ton disque dur et à deux
terrains à choeung ek son frère pour
simuler lambert soit excusé un peu le
truc tu as encore se faire recaler on va
partir sur ce thème là on
commence par quoi une petite progression
d'accords quatre accords en boucle c'est
la recette
je veux trouver une petite pépite de la
santé
[Musique]
j'adore c'est vraiment caisse des
moments où avec une poule désaccords et
les autres sont comme ça je vais voir
c'est bien ça pour le côté un peu polka
de l'est ils font un côté un peu foire à
la saucisse au curry vénère vaty fois
ouais ouais voilà voilà voilà ça
pourrait être un truc un peu comme ça
quoi
[Musique]
cette fois ça a très bien fait
l'eurovision je vais les écouter aux
portes moi j'arrive à mon avis ils sont
pas aussi rapide que toi tu mets juste
inquiet pour qu'on se
complique
c'est de la machine à
menacer de lamatina offriront je pense
qu'ils sont bratisla boys ont jeté
il nous faut la basse électronique de
malades des années 2000 et qui tuent
sans l'électricité qui passe dedans et
que
tu vois de quoi je parle et c'est de
trouver le preset en question
voilà
[Musique]
papapapa
ça c'est mieux mais comment suivre ce
truc de c'est vraiment ballot faut
suivre le truc d'argent exactement y
paraît
[Musique]
ah ben voilà
alors c'était ça des petites belle
aurait pu m'arriver
[Musique]
attend maintenant on attend la tempe et
un truc là c'est bien d'un produit gm
avec ce prêt à temps mais voilà tac ça
respire et
savoir comment cela s'est bien sûr il
faut garder des petits éléments de
structure comme ça l'a déjà c'est pas
mal moi je pense pour reprendre les
trucs ajustements dans ozone c'est un
perso qui parle avec un nombre de
syllabes dans cet open précis et le
perso d'après reprend le nombre de
syllabes et les paroles mais ils
interprètent différemment et de leur
table et tout en fait dans les années de
lui je trouve y avait beaucoup de culot
moi j'aimerais bien qu'ils aient un
instrument chelou qu'on n'entend nulle
part aujourd'hui et qu'on n'entendait
pas forcément beaucoup non plus dans les
années 2000 mais qu'ils fassent ce
qu'elles sont il est reconnaissable dès
la première seconde mais ce que je veux
dire que vous voulez c'est assez
satisfaisant ils sont comme ça t'en
matheron il faut qu'on trouve un
trouvons un truc est-ce que par une
flûte qui dirait
c'est trop tôt c'est trop tôt une
cornemuse en corner
3e condat their peut-être ajouter unis
dont nous avons la moyenne il a un truc
qui glisse
fringe et fiac à manger tue un monstre
d'un zelda il a fait les mêmes bruits à
[Musique]
oui
merci merci
je connais
[Musique]
alors voilà de secours plus de ses vues
et revues accordéon c'est peut-être trop
nostalgique
en captant vas-y clavecin
ah ouais pas mal
non mais il faut écrire comme une sorte
de parodie
une partition genre de musique classique
ou les vois tu peux cliquer ne peut pas
le jouer mais je peux le clic et le clip
est ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'il
va le tu va le jouer en mettant les
notes d'un logiciel plutôt que de le
jouer au piano man c'est ça voilà c'est
ça
[Musique]
j'adore elle sans avancer ça peut
peut-être un truc mais gare important
est reconnaissable du morceau la leçon
il commence comme ça
alors au début ce qu'on peut faire c'est
voix simuler une entrée droite et on
rentrera sûrement la fin j'espère pour
toi
ah ouais t'as tellement que c'était
pâtissent qu'on recalcule va quand même
en boîte bien sûr
c'est pas mon problème je m'appelle je
rappelle bien la pga en appel un peu de
magie à l'eau
les seconds on arrive à vous j'ai pas
fait vous discret on a chez vous
[Musique]
à des logiciels s'est fermé happening
numéro un vous cache pas que j'ai pensé
à rien du tout d'ailleurs je vais aller
leur rendre visite j'arrive
thibault
super look à la personne
je suis un bâtard je peux en bâtard je
suis un bâtard je crois pas tort c'est
l'anniversaire d'un mec qui s'appelle
masqué donc je pense vous toqué il ouvre
la porte et quand il ou vous faites bon
anniversaire masqués s'étaient
rencontrés dans la pièce c'est là où je
suis en vacances je suis un bâtard je
suis un bâtard je suis un bâtard
punchy keek vous n'arrêtez pas tant que
nous on n'est pas descendu vous dire
d'aed ok ça du tout ok les gars
j'ai filmé tous leurs écrans j'ai le nom
des kits moi j'ai pas voulu mettre plein
je suis un bâtard comment t'as fait crac
est venu comme ça ils n'étaient pas dans
le studio moment là bas ils sont en
train de préparer un coup tu crois quoi
frère à la guerre comme à la guerre
alors
il arrive à
les enrichir bon y'a pas un game qui
traîne
attends mais
bon
ouais
[Applaudissements]
il faut une bonne demi-heure de bonnes
affaires en boucle si je voudrais plus
jamais vivre à l'adresse faire de sa vie
on va devoir prouver comme ça ça
s'arrête
[Musique]
oh
merci beaucoup
voilà pour l'instant on va le garder un
peu smooth comme ça quand on met avec le
clavecin
sa venue mettre une petite couche un peu
plus moderne au classement et ensuite
cette chaîne de bourrin qui était la
mode à l'époque ça itx mc ces cantons
qui qui il fait baisser tout le reste ça
fait
[Musique]
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup c'était
super non non non non on
doit travailler
et vous ont payé pour jeu combien de
temps que
jusqu'à 50 d'après midi
[Musique]
en votant lucas thomas da et si on fait
si on chante vraiment dans une langue
autre que français il faut il faut qu'on
chante vraiment des mots je veux faux
pas de yahoo c'est trop facile voilà
faut vraiment chanter dans la vraie
langue quitte à prendre un prof tu vois
bah on est obligés sinon on va dire du
google traduction et c'est chiant je
m'entends que ce soir demain je vous
annonce la news si c'est oui ou non
comme ça ça m'a un petit bémol est pour
vous
nos attentes en attendant toucheront
plus une bagarre c'est une bagarre qui
revient sur rue sont en train de mettre
des coups de trompette au
sens où ça sort d'où son nom je prépare
t allez on y va on va voir lucas allen
levé vous vous levez vous je sais pas
comment réagir
c'est pas moi aussi mais moi j'en peux
plus
ah ouais
tu te la mort fait ce réflexe
gomis
super gars
grave avancé
ils ont fait 30 minutes de l'année
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci les gars merci bon pour la mission
merci mr s'est beaucoup c'était
incroyable
se
cache pas jeter dedans de retirer mon
masque
bouger d'ici là
je pense que vous vous êtes partition un
truc à la cool coucou coucou josh et
trompa les années 2000 ces gens aux
sommes à l'écouté
york se vendent bien des raisons écouter
mais ils ont écouté au summum âgées
crédibilité ce qu'on a fait mais de la
victime comme moi qu'une craint moins à
nantes est ils ont fait un truc à la
zone c est pourquoi tu ne regardes pas
dans les yeux quand tu dis ça parce que
je regarde c'est typiquement ce qu'un
mec aurait fait s'il avait fait un truc
j'en ferai le double
j'en ai jamais tu viens ici voyage my
house revient
jamais de ma vie je regarde marcos c'est
bon
la lutte à deux c'est bon j'ai eu ma
dose j'arrête franchement je les
anniversaires merci mon rôle nous on est
resté une minute c'était épuisant ils
sont lessivés ils ont plus d'énergie
pour le sont car seul un commentaire 10e
anniversaire what else dont des
sénégalais il me reste plus beaucoup
avant la trentaine
non on peut pas les laisser nous faire
des salles comme ça demain on est censé
faire quoi on leur amène une riche
partie un mec acté avec les enceintes
comme ça là demain et on la ramène des
gens qui font la fête en rave party ou
bien non mais ça c'est dit me dis le
c'est en quoi j'ai pensé à ça je dis
bien on la renvoie nîmes bat usa au fond
de la pièce tu sais c'est déstabilisant
quand tu me poses une chanson il ya
quelqu'un derrière
[Rires]
ce sont ça s'appelle un orchestra it
ce petit on parle de ça ce truc là
normalement c'est typique années 90 mais
pour le mettre dans un truc qui vient
d'europe de l'est en 2000 voilà ce que
c'est bien à la bâtisse un peu comme
l'instrument bizarre qu'on a mis c'est
un bios genre et c'est audacieux gestion
et non pas audacity parce qu'il est un
logiciel qui crachent beaucoup qui
crache et harmonique et de la lumière
c'est horrible décide je peux pas te
laisser dire ça à mende il ya énormément
de gens qui commencent avec audace sur
youtube aurait que tous nos voix avec
audacity base il ne reste que tu meurs
tu viens de critiquer salut à tous est
ce que vous avez envie de suisse et une
tétine en tant qu'adulte mans pourtant
vous avez commencé avec ça
on finit notre propre nous paraissent
pouvoir et nous on fait quoi là on était
sur l'intro je me rappelle de tout même
commente était habillé il ya deux jours
du coup pour l'entre-deux choix juste un
petit synthé comme ça tu vois avec les
drogues
dans un an
voilà
je veux pas rajouter les bruits
d'ambiance qu'on avait là je pense ça
peut le faire n'ont vu que ça fait
rentrer deux boîtes
[Musique]
c'est beaucoup
et
m
attends attends je l'avais qu'ils
arrêtent pour demain fut son conte
lagarde s'annonce assez chaud sa place
mais son refrain ou d'un couplet mois
l'âge et moi je pensais leur offrant un
emprunt
à l'égard en quarts ce truc là mais
après quand c'est rigolo ouais
aller
[Applaudissements]
la fin du morceau ça se terminera comme
ça les gars c'est pas mal nouvelle
mission nous structurer au moins qu'on
ait des intros groupe ouais voilà qu'on
puisse ensuite demain bosser les top
line et tous les gars je pense que on
est bon là on va aller se reposer ou on
va les digérer et prévoir notre plan
surtout pour demain je pense alors là on
a une mission on va trouver une femme
qui a une voix qui pourrait correspondre
à l'esthétique de son est indigne j'ai
posé un petite idée de ce concert
complet refrain couplet refrain on vire
décroché de machin est
complet
[Musique]
avec la fsa qui revient c'est bien
refrain
on a de quoi faire des top line demain
les gens d'air c'est une expression d'un
rap qui s'appelle éteinte son ennemi de
ce groupe c'est lourd soit mais attendez
zain
dans ce cas je pense qu'à chance car des
regards
la passion n'a rien du tout
dans l'olympia une expression sont pas
là on n'est pas tard je voulais les
éteindre mais
non il veut nous c'est un piège c'est un
piège je ne touche pas ce temps dit
c'est un piège au méchoui yoshida
êtes vous fiers de ce que vous avez
produit aujourd'hui justement l'extrême
en comptant tout est fini la proie des
fêtes s'est structuré demain c'est quoi
cet open des paroles pour vous aussi
mais t'inquiète pas pour demain on
connaîtra mieux ton sont que toi même on
prend nos casques de moto tu crois pas
si bien dire moi regarde horaire dgh
j'ai une vision demain ça à toquer à la
porte on va faire oui entre et là il ya
trois individus qui vont entrer qui vont
faire les gars parce que
l'un de vous trois vaches les chiens les
chats les chiens les langues de travail
année les gains ne pas
aller là ça prend une dimension ce qu'on
appelle leur nom ne sonne pas toi bon
bah dégâts à demain on suit note
l'isolella bisous à tous il ya un mot de
passe sur leur dire merde
[Musique]
messieurs dames nous sommes de bonne
humeur ce matin oui nous sommes arrivés
une heure plus tôt pour faire un petit
sabotage dans leur studio je dis pas ce
que c'est mais nous on sait et quel
plaisir en fait c'est improbable que ce
genre de chose est possible en aussi peu
de temps c'est la magie de ce que
l'espèce est ce matin cette idée est
prête dans le studio de l'équipe adverse
est tout simplement ils ne peuvent pas
travailler
qu est ce qu un film déjà super ça sent
le piège là attendez deux secondes
le micro
j en micro monsieur se foutent de notre
gueule ils se foutent de notre gueule
[ __ ] sans pâte à modeler regardez
croissance moi c'est un gâteau non c'est
un gâteau
les enceintes et cissé ndinga taux
extrêmement bas cette nuit ça a dit
haffner saadiq taponner je sais petit
couplet un petit refrain
sept jours dans cette joute qui nous
envoyait un temple hindou sétois elle
est excellente le gaming et tête à un
faux de la répétition
et résister faire écouter non mais
attends mais qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait
du vrai micro je vais aller voir lucas
tu vas aller le voir ouais je vois les
gens le voient à lui
il faut qu'on ait plus de limites
possibles dans ce morceau le roumain
c'est bien c'est parfait pour ce qu'on
raconte mais il nous faut un moment avec
des hyènes onomatopées je sais pas
quelque chose j'avais une petite idée
vas-y
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour
versées à temps mais qu'est ce que c'est
qu'est ce qui se passe les gars pourquoi
nous ensemble c'est un gâteau et notre
micro aussi au ciné woulé sur tik tok je
peux voir jeu super bon mais quand
malone et evans ont pas venir voir on
peut devenir membre vous pouvez venir
pour what the fuck mec ça a été remplacé
pour les quatre ouais les mecs ils sont
bons joueurs sur ta vie
mais voilà ils nous ont pas suivis créé
par un truc
[Musique]
commencer un gâteau
voilà
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup
des
voix commencent à couler ramener les
deux enceintes rémi creton tu ramènes
tout mon travail ne te jure sur certains
autres amène tous aller d'après les
gains sont pas des gens simples il a dit
a pris le club des anciens des gars moi
j'ai les mains prises par les enceintes
le vaccin
la tête il a fait l était pas sur nous
et
merci merci beaucoup non non non non non
messieurs une autre non
oh
la tête que masque rien fait et 100%
réel ils nous détestent la l'heure
actuelle pour durer à tueur est ou
qu'elle occupe à sir detroit il était là
genre quitte à casser les couilles
[Musique]
de même m
sakri j'aime bien ça laissons le liait à
usher et au r'n'b et nous on prend le ja
qui est bien plus pour le plus aux rites
folklorique on enregistre la top line
[Musique]
chaque coup de pompe est chaque coup de
trompette c'est vraiment une tarte dans
la gueule
[Musique]
j'aime proposer et vient de mourir en
son temps un bon c'est vraiment un drift
de voiture
oh
[Musique]
non ok moi j'ai des idées pour les
couplets je vous ai dit que pour les
couplets je voulais qu'ils aient ce truc
voix grave vous avez vu la voiture
reprend lé nombre de syllabes
un truc genre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant
opposés tous composés tout comme ça nous
on a une idée du coût global
allez merci d'être venu ça nous plaît
énormément
merci
merci beaucoup tu es mon meilleur ami
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
[ __ ] j'espère ne jamais les revoir ils
ont toujours pas d'enceintes en bas
j'espère que non ils ont pu malade
chimay plus dans cinq mois elles sont là
elles sont là elles sont là elles sont
là les enceintes et où olivier ce que tu
peux juste venir quand je crée le plan
la revanche qui est la brique est juste
là bonjour bonjour enchanté à vous
parler toi il faudrait un petit couplet
m il y avait un truc c'était assez
comment dans les années 2000 machin
c'était d'avoir un break du rap pour ben
service avec ton personne telle gastrite
baghi qui fait son break et sombre ekra
toi tu es le gain un peu androgyne
séchant toujours en mode méga
interprétation point elles mêmes limites
un peu lyrique ont fait et moi je suis
le mec un peu genre qui fait grave c'est
le néo de matrix telle loi dans la la la
la ils essaient mais la donatrice way
fait ça donne moi la bulle et le rouge à
quoi ouais désolé j'ai juste mes
affaires que je dois déposer mais pour
être même pas des affaires dans son
studio parce qu'il a pris place en fait
à cause du gâteau est aussi l'affront du
bal où et quand ce local je les loue
elle ça fait un an et demi que ça fait
un an et nick taylor que je sois je me
disais à toutes les gares
alors qu'avons nous dans ce sac ça c'est
pas fait les affaires des gens
non non oui
c'est l'ancien locataire à ce qui paraît
il habitait juste là en face du micro
les seconds on voulait salir l'image du
job des secours c'est bon allez même un
monde parle pas
essayée
à la chanson
par contre les gars moi je vous dis
c'est pas moi qui paie c'est pas moi qui
fait la voix du refrain non mais on
avait dit il faut il faut du beau c'est
bon là bah ouais c est ce qu on la
ramène on la ramène je vais la chercher
à alès go je te feras un papillon ouais
à papillons papillon du bonheur oh c'est
très fragile à dire qu'un instant
ces journées 1 h 28
yes let's go home on présente bon dieu
ça va pas
on prend un peu de temps oui
on prend un peu de temps on a juste des
top line up on doit règles de sa voix je
suis pas un robot non plus en bon je
suis pas un robot mais bon c'est moche
par un robot dit on trouve ça le fait
bien
et c'est un monde bosse mais non ces
paravents modifie pas que ça c'est pas
un robot alors le thème d'aujourd'hui si
je te dis au summum de 113 ça te parle
mon enfance mon enfance à guilers on a
une top line qui est pas mal que pour la
tous validés moi je propose qu'on sent
j'avais d'abord tout sur sur la prod
celui qui a des idées proposées balance
mais on a déjà une idée pour leurs
offres je peux en rose et il ya les
autres ou à troisvaux trompe c'est quoi
comme un mois c'est un gros sapin
c'est spirituel incertain de l'intérieur
vous venez nombreuses années et tout
chronofoot faut évacuer monsieur désolé
monsieur s'est désolé vous la met un
alors moi c'est un frêne monsieur c'est
d'abord regardé au pavot à faire
regarder merci beaucoup croyable merci
beaucoup
j'ai vécu à venir au moment de mon
existence je suis fanatique de crime
[Musique]
hamon alors j'adore manger un truc je
gamberge vendanges avec moi-même
j'arrive hockey a tout de suite non
c'est très rapide la fibre optique ah
ouais voir au delà de nos limites foire
au délà devenu limite tu peux le faire
se peut les voir au delà de nos limites
ok + limite tu as genre plus ce bye bye
annonce bizarre tu montes a muté
monsieur
[Musique]
olalala à versailles merci à lèvres et
le mouv micro ronan les oiseaux se plie
après par contre pour le pour la suite j
plombe
les gars vous souvenez des op line au
moins
il a pris un top line
et off line aux idées car je suis aux
filles aux
fiches army officiel bo fi nal au final
officiel c'est pas mal à vous y
retrouver le
nom en anglais dans les années 2000 les
langues ça n'existait pas pour l'instant
parce que je vous propose c'est qu'on le
fasse avec des mots ont fait on fait
n'importe quoi en mode top line on
commence par le refrain le fait chacun
de deux tours qui commence je suis très
chaud on case
en case
moi j'aime bien le délire de ce soir il
aimait bien indiquer ce qu'ils allaient
passer dans la soirée tu vois à
l'ancienne voie
de la ligne ce soit avant
ou quoi s'illumine à médis bout moi ça
me va aussi
mais au delà
parce que
on est au fils jacques rosselin grâce la
gamme des musées avec modération
l'illumination se fait par la santé en
français où la gueule
on va voir à peu près les trois en même
temps
[Musique]
c'est pas mal ça marche chez les gens et
on comprend
[Musique]
quelle interprétation
là je pense qu'on mélodie on est bon non
faut que ça qui
[Musique]
m
ats
qui valide tout c'est top line 1 2 3 ans
je vivais jeand'heur oui
[Musique]
olé
oh la la
ok tu sais ce crime qu il voit du papier
du bois du papier et un stylo face à moi
la cellulose alors si noah pum tu vois
ta main vasilescu augmente des cahiers
chrono a fait le break rap dans la prod
est aussi la trouvez comment sont
personne va poser on prend les paroles
du refrain flow 2000 pas de triplé de
flou pas de trucs moderne pas devant un
champ et où on est old school terroriste
iranien j'écoutais pas à
[Musique]
yangon
excellence et que le truc arrive comme
il repart quoi ouais enfin ils veulent
la force il fait jour vous essayer au
yoyo et
ont taillé l'offre hp a pris goût à
l'écriture elle m'inspire pas du tout
unique elles sont si j'écris sur un
cahier je veux ni quelqu'un va me remet
elle s'en remet elles sont
[Musique]
déjà les bras croisés qui connaît les
attentes croissantes du projet 10 et
ambulants scandale tu connais déjà
ambiance scandale ouais c'est ça le
prend au nom de groupes bien fondé d'un
scandale avec un cac à
un jeune fille qui seront bientôt jeunes
racontent et c nous dès qu'on entend
c'est hangers who que ça scandaleux du
commerce dans les couloirs comme ça la
qualité de ses ambiances ordonne voiture
à la maison c'est une bonne ambiance
je repense à un truc pour le clip est
tout même si c'est le sujet de demain le
truc du times que tu as dit c'est une
excellente idée les années 2000 y avait
vraiment ce délire de vision du futur
nul moi je pense que ce qu'on peut
peut-être faire ce qui marche bien c'est
de mettre un bruit d'horloge le pire
cliché mais à guam et ça marche bien
mais c'est ça en fait il n'était pas
feinte par exemple pourraient le [ __ ]
avant le avant de refrains ça pourrait
donner ça
c'est très bien faut pas non plus sûrs
d'eux et je pense que ce truc de
trotteuse d'assez excès on avance petit
à petit ça veut dire que l'équipe d'en
face avance petit à petit ça veut dire
qu'il faut qu'on ok ok mais la pente
nous apprenons que
[Musique]
je pourrai pas le faire avec la mention
je sais pas ce qui m'a pris là j'étais
dehors ouais maintenant je suis dedans
un cheveu gominé je fais le petit pas de
danse à la somme était due penneteau
avance à tonton ils ont de la calebasse
maintenant t'as jamais vu le poids face
à son nom mais c'est le même emballage
que la colle forte a besoin et où les un
premier déjà premier couplet donne moi
une minute vas-y et 7e puis ça pour le
couple et huawei et on va faire qu'une
seule prise et c'est là qu'on va
regarder vas-y l'énergie j'aime bien à
voter pour moi je pourrais pas faire ça
je te dis directeur dit
les gars
explose ça c'est vos tenues
hop gillet gillet et c'est ce qu'il faut
qu'on fasse il faut qu'on se mette des
masques parce qu'il faut pas qu'ils ne
reconnaissent way vas-y je pose la date
où le couple est là j'espère jouer au
pire on raccourcit allez c'est parti
est-ce que même en plus des intrus dans
le casque et
ses envies en scandale tu connais déjà
les deux bras croisés connaît le bas ce
soir on s'est mis ne s'assimile pas par
nous en français fra 1 pense me mine à
londres décrit le rêve avant de les
réaliser apprend à nous connaître avant
de nous pénaliser faire tamil et ce sur
composant les chaussettes c'est commode
c'est une mauvaise idée les spreads
entre les chaînes s'abritant qu'elle a
dit 'nous on s'engage on commence à puer
bon sens même les tours dont danse
champions comme les cinq champions du
gard gard naoum à l'ancienne
[Applaudissements]
les sky est trop fils olivier je pense
non c'est chaud c'est chaud c'est bon tu
l'as tu là vas-y toi tu tapes line du
coup au mot dreamcoat rapide
official donc ici me d'ebit et dvd
j'étais dehors et maintenant je suis
dedans je veux gominés je fais le petit
pas de danse j'étais dehors et
maintenant je suis dedans cheveux
gominés je fais le petit pas de danse
kabze près et à falloir être extra
efficacement
laisse rendrait le flair manqué de
perdre ses nerfs c'est en
fait tout de suite on le fait tout ce
scandale fait au crime non en forêt avec
forex après que ça
s tout appui rec et puis tu cours ici
comme ça tu vas ans et créé le scandale
avec nous tu vois le scandale qui vient
du club
quel happening
classement bien jouer squeeze je peux
pas les en sortir
percer la porte c'est pas possible
c'était un peu regardez les ils se font
passer pour les ouvriers pense que ce
n'est pas cramé dans le mur allait
descendre mais est en prison terminée
mais il faut quand même qu'on le pose de
cinq ans meurent cela jouera cherchant
vite vite vite vite vite excuse comme ça
on finit on s'en bat les couilles laisse
entrer le tarmac verte cnrc angel est
déjà très bon très sale
c'est bon tu peux nous casser les
couilles du cac puis cassé tu peux nous
casser comme tu veux parce qu'on a fait
après les travaux la super compétences
et ouvrir à tout à l'heure bisous les
hôpitaux ok il est aux mines à temps on
capte mal
moi je me pose montrait bien en
besoins des gens qui se cachent t'as pas
vu qu'on est humide parce que là moi
j'ai un ouvrier qui est venu ici il ya
des travaux à faire vous aussi vous avez
vu ça et me dit leo
non moi j'ai pas vu minh a un mec moi ça
fait une heure une heure qui sont partis
mais je pense qu'ils ont kidnappés mis
des chronos je pense aussi un tutu peut
enquêter pas si je te trouves tes deux
acolytes masi dix jours
c'est dommage [ __ ] ils cherchent mid
assez bon d'accord du ses deux
coéquipiers je m'en bats les couilles
parce que nous
quel fiasco [ __ ]
radio nous on écoute le son
pour
tous les sens hôtel à port
la nouvelle à bois les
[Applaudissements]
rejeter l'erreur mais j'attends
d'entendre ça c'est acquis le faire ça
c'est le dj dj ah ouais je paye rien
l'écran regarde que moi tu meurs à gérer
bien ça j'ai l'impression d'être dans
les faits ce n'était
pas si
tu peux le tourner maintenant qu'il est
là ou pas
au nord
on abandonne au fils de [ __ ] 10 de peter
mullan si
j'étais tellement pas nécessaire lagarde
mission accomplie au canon plus tôt
voilà
on a une info on sait qu'il ya une
chanteuse dans leur équipe oui oui je
les veux aussi il ya une meuf qui est
assez avec moi donc c'est bel et bien un
son du 113 parce que les refrains voix
féminine ses 113 ces années 2000 rennes
nbc va bosser sur sézanne les gars bravo
c'est un succès on a une informatique c
c des branches et c'est bon cassez comme
dans prison break ou coiffe avec les
tailles et les seconds
n'ont pas de rivalité icimod je
voulais messieurs vous présenter notre
professeur aujourd'hui messieurs du
bruit pour en cas
en cas les amis professeurs de roumains
c'est grâce à cette personne que nous
allons écrire cette musique sans en cas
nous ne sommes rien aujourd'hui que tu
saches pour le moment il ya du google
traduction de roumains il ya du
n'importe quoi donc faut qu'on réussisse
à coller des vrais mots est il vrai
histoire sur une mélodie de voix on peut
quand même te faire écouter le son il ya
ouvert et après tous ensemble on trouve
les thèmes et trouver le nom du morceau
est le nom du groupe
[Musique]
la balle
est
[Applaudissements]
hors
d'eau
[Musique]
génial
donc nous on a juste des mots qu'on est
obligé de mettre parce qu'il y aura un
thème dans le clip qui est le voyage
dans le temps donc la montagne on est
obligé de le garder mais la première
partie cette phrase on peut le dire aux
roumains c'est pas grave tu vois donc le
thème c'est le voyage dans le temps oui
et c'est toi la profession franchement
c'est aux tables ah bah oui
son frenchy ça veut dire quoi je suis
heureux se félicite je suis homo ensuite
nous disait quoi ça maroc alors je suis
heureux de manger voilà ça madame ça
veut dire de manger je suis heureux de
manger une pastèque c'était ça condamné
à
une pme la pastèque faut garder ses
forces ok mais là il ya une phrase qui
fait petit
syllabes comment tu dirais je veux que
ça dure toute la vie c'est mon
professeur tu vas vous voici qu'au club
la prochaine fois que tu mets du respect
tu sors et si on vient d un truc genre
il ya peu de pépins ont mis à zéro pépin
en fait parce que ça peut être une
métaphore de la vie où la vie est une
pastèque avec plus ou moins de pépins
selon les turbulences que sont le fil de
votre vie c'est sans pépins farah
symbole c'est bon on est d'accord que ça
veut dire je suis heureux que je ne
mange une pastèque sans doute pas sans
pépins
ok paraît parfait
n36 l'armée on a dit pépé n'est non pas
dire autre chose il faut un mot en trois
syllabes en y qui finit par y attendait
un truc genre attendez attendez tous
terriblement acheter de tati stats là on
reconnaît de la chance donc nos idées
finissent pas et en rumantsch et ces
gens-là probable et la proba et les
maigres et si je dirais allons-y
venez ça s'il y venait venez pas mal des
mythes ou venez bénédicte l'élite
excellent à laisser traîner base et non
pas tout on va tous dans le dire oui
[Musique]
là c'est le refrain la halle en gros le
proposer on voyage dans le temps c'était
une caste ville qui veut rien dire m
time time je pense que vous gardez time
time en grèce il n'y a pas eu de se
promener où on bouge dans le temps on
danse dans le to a pas mal dans dix ans
je serai pas un poète toi motus le fait
qu'il va aller le sujet avec moi c'est
avec un style r'n'b et vous êtes
collègues ça donne ça nintendo
nintendogs et on se dit bye-bye toi ok à
chaque
fois que bye bye ouais c'est ça là on a
12 syllabes avant le times time c'est
décidé on repart voyager dans le times
tard arrive un truc comme ça on est prêt
à partir ouais sainté ngata sakho la
taurine
vas-y tu peux pas vous voulez bien
l'écrire une heure de colle play
calciné
deuxième couplet et tata parce que
pendant ce qu'on pourrait faire là qui
marcherait pas pas mal ces deux
lister les époques on peut dire
moyen-âge antiquités
sont faits les deux sites wathier
difficile à mener
tiens ce trail moi tu dis l'antiquité
les gars les gars je pense qu'on est bon
pour aujourd'hui non non non je dis on
peut pas se reposer faucon manigances
messieurs messieurs la mission est
presque terminée et nous reste deux
choses quand même importante le nom du
son et le nom du groupe le nom du groupe
a comme on dit tu dis il montre qu as tu
as de chasse a fait chiasse un panneau
chiasse moi ça fait un peu cher et les
doigts tu dis que mon job d'être gt il
est bien calé dès sa nazis douar el hadj
est 3 doigts je trouve ça très chaud en
boule c'est trop bien pour une amitié tu
vois ça veut dire qu'on peut commencer
le son et faire ça et que sur la
pochette mais face à de
maintenant il faut le nom du son moi je
vous le dis en anglais on dit trade
j'étais le times time travel offre comme
ça juste pas une prime time time c'est
très bien trade j'étais time time c'est
un moment je me sens les gars fin de la
journée deux
allers les lots
[Musique]
de
samaa et
[Applaudissements]
on avait vu grâce à la caméra nobody
toeger
parce qu'on n'est pas favoris comme
idéal 213 nominaux fin du jour 2 vous
avez posé des voix du coup là c'est les
mêmes équipements que les mecs qui m'ont
fait ch et à leurs noms seront pas mais
tu sais là c'est ce que je me disais
ils reprennent être workers et tout
comme kara retrait prenne ce risque
d'être de collection il reste quoi faire
demain du goût poser un couple et avant
de graver ça sur un cd un an grâce à son
cd en grave ça sur des chaînes hi fi et
où chaîne hi fi non mortels de malras
vous le juge sera là pour juger notre de
son et on lui ferait à l'écouté du coup
dans une chaîne hi-fi surin s'est
dégradée comme des années 2000 comme il
se doit et aussi demain vous bris frais
théo qui réalisera votre clip et nous
aussi cette année on met le paquet sur
le clip non les bras croisés là ça se
voit certes a coûté cher
ça c'est très coûteux sert là demain 11
heures j'en ai trois jours j ai
peut-être des happenings de voir ici
watercat ah oui peut-être beau prenez
soin de vous bosse ici aussi attention
j'adore la tradition s'applaudit oui
avec 7 mai en plein
jour numéro pts donc là je dois poser
mon couple et j'ai déjà détruit quand tu
es qui ajuste sur la fin où je bug un
peu mais je suis bien entouré moi je
vais poser des bac tu vois à l'époque
j'aimais bien appuyer les mots les goûts
on y va on aura les bacs les ambiances
une petite ambiance les ambiances et
après le mix aussi
graveur que j'ai failli [ __ ] web basés
en masse pense qu'il faut pas perdre de
temps y est c'est parti on a une heure
trente pour faire simple petite
précision un son en 1h30 ça commence
maintenant dégager un cadeau pour vous
c'est sur ça que va finir notre le bourg
qu'on mettrait notre sont sur un truc
pour faire fuir les oiseaux mais déjà
travaillons prendront toutes ces voix
mixons sont parce qu'il faut le mix est
là c'est vraiment étroite avec mazda
leur jugement je suis excité parce qu'on
va entendre leur songer à brac est à
dubaï
va est là qu'ils ont fait un saut comme
ça
aff je veux la phase aiguë ou grave
celle là le hoya hier m'a dit fais
écouter
[Musique]
on imagine ça pourrait être mon réveil
le matin c'est horrible à vos 10 kg 11
à l'eau est en tournage pour nos enfants
c'est séminal on l'a écrit nos rêves
avant de les réaliser apprendre à nous
connaître avant de pénaliser pareil en
cas en bien ok
je me disais ça fait plaisir comme ça je
vais essayer de le faire on pas nul ce
soir en éliminant sa cellule apparemment
français trompant subliminal ont écrit
en français france panneaux en français
par subliminal
ce sens et les mines à sa cellule par
arnaud en français pensent subliminal
parce que la vision claire
des faux culs
official donc que ces multi voici ces
bons garde sa garde ça on enchaîne les
clips du ne fut pas l'équipe pas mal ça
c'est chaud c'est qu'il équipe tu sais
nous défier l'équipe c'est l'équipe type
mais l'ambiance
est bonne et non ce matin jusqu'à une
crâne leur argent soit toi laisse bon
niveau dans beaucoup de sports tout le
pouls quatre groupes les plus son permis
non
dans tout sport tu me booster on est des
classes d'été le docteur et bien
ok donc on a ça à temps c'est plus
facile allez trouver là dessus
c'est là tu peux la face à la russie à
ce que bamba est plus que c'est
vraiment un excellent excellent très
propre ce sont chez nous donc je place
mes places le sait les journaux anselmo
tu connais le verdict ce soir où la
serbie avec le son de chez nous près
encore un hoquet une variété une variété
de bach
avec le sont je joue ouais ouais un port
d'où
[Musique]
part en full hd remis en jeu que son
chouchou voilà lazaret équipe de rugby
mur
tu en avais une première très au sérieux
j'ai oublié
ce soir
[Musique]
on
vient d'inventer les polyphonies corses
c'est incroyable la liste est longue des
choses qui nous reste à faire noah
mix master et il nous reste treize
minutes messieurs le moment préféré des
gens les anims est-ce qu'on va briller
mes chronos c'est une excellente
question mais petit répond qu'est-ce
qu'un à l'ipp adlib c'est vraiment
libres les lèvres la voie à d une
addition de paroles ne sont pas les
paroles principal mais qu'on ajoute une
couche en dessous ça va l'aider à adé eu
une répétition de mots importants qui
vont donner un peu de vie au morceau et
mettre en avant certaines parties qui
nous feront plaisir
tu as jardiniers des qr codes et quand
us can now une vidéo et ses
abîmes ce grand moment de creech pas
autant que le mine mais pas loin c'est
parti
oui
ok cros motiva je vais faire des bacs de
rap et raï
[Applaudissements]
mais rigolo
20h02 rien de pire aux américains trade
and
too
bad times bye bye a perdu ses repères ok
vas-y dans ce mois
open a fait quelques rires des rires de
fond
[Musique]
maintenant l'étape où il se passe pas
grand chose ou alors mais nécessaire il
va se passer beaucoup de choses mais pas
grand chose à québec voilà moi moi tu
sais ce que je pense qu'il faut faire
faut leur envoyer une dérive la
dinguerie pour moi c'est le son fowler
envoyé une deuxième d'un deuxième
d'agréer voilà il reste plus beaucoup de
temps histoire qu'ils aient encore moins
de temps restons très confiants sur pc
avec tolga de vos trucs
you hell au salut à l'équipe vous n'êtes
pas trop à l'étroit ici on voulait se
répéter un petit peu et dès que vous
êtes prévenus dont je vous envoie au et
ben moi je vais lever le doublé avec un
juste un truc qui va graver un monde où
les ans on abat rendre visite
[Musique]
bonjour
c'est bon ça dure ça y est opposée
on a le temps d'en faire deux autres new
way ben c'est pas un opc panoplie qu'il
fallait faire basket est juste venu de
dire bonjour ya rien de mes mecs on
dirait je dois être suspect spécialement
c'est quoi déjà mais je sais pas chanter
but est vraiment de bonne humeur pas
aujourd'hui pourquoi vous êtes en mx 1
et mx marocaines sont bonnes aujourd'hui
bienveillance et hameaux j'avais en
sergé du l'homme a tout ruiné maison mon
frère nick ce bon les envoie maintenant
bizarres des séries
you à vous êtes encore là vous êtes de
retour non
ça très bien
alors autant vouloir casser le pays
pendant dix minutes allez les gars
avaient oublié votre équipe c'est pas
mon équipe c'est courbevoie où je suis
de la courneuve
la petite bourse c'est quoi la place
beauvau il a trouvé l'endroit est bien
faire la fête dans le 2e arrondissement
attendez les gars vous faire dit il vous
ne me laissez travailler si ça peut vous
combien je peux dire la petite bourse 10
fois ça c'est sans toit et à chaque fois
que dit la petite bosse vous crier fort
la petite bourse la petite bourse la
petite bouffe et tous les soirs en fait
là pas où la voiture le soir sa ceinture
et
tous les sens on fait un pas
ce soir c'est li mickey
way toutes les bourses ouais tu te
bourse
ok vous êtes place goho mios chanteur
anglais
ok
et et conclut la porte
les quatre jours on leur dira que
c'était trop relou qu'on n'en peut plus
et voici voulais je vais les voir et je
dis les gars c'est bon ils nous ont tiré
dessus pendant mille ans tout ça comme
ça il souhaite en faire un masque et à
l'égard d'un stop la mi-mars à la stoppe
ont été
arrêtés
[Applaudissements]
j'ai pas entendu
c'était quoi le haka parce que j'ai
vraiment très bien la merci de tous ces
bons l'aura bien casser les couilles
aller au match aller je paye pas ce
talent rugby un big up à la petite
bourse évidemment on teste les amours de
ouf ouais
pour qu'ils appuient vraiment sur ce
très
bon là on a ce qui s'appelle un premix
mais au montage et c'est pareil pour
l'équipe de masques et vous vous
entendrez les vrais sont dave pas dans
leur entièreté vous entendrez le son en
entier uniquement quand sortira lé qu
est-ce qu on grave ce sont allés tu sais
comment graver un cd
bah c'est une nouvelle épreuve dès qu'on
rallonge le concours d'une semaine en
bas ils sont aussi en train de grimper
leur céder pendant que tu cherches comme
j'avais cdg une nouvelle incroyable zone
c les gars on n'allait pas finir sans un
peu nîmes mais là par contre si vous
voulez dinguerie chemin inverse j'ai
pour projet de mme infiltrés dans le
studio de l'équipe de masquer et
d'échanger leurs cd avec un autre cd sur
lequel j'aurai grave eux la musique des
mariachis
pour sagem gordhan rappelle de nous vous
m'aurez un talkie walkie si on réussit
l'occasion se régler ça veut dire que
quand ils vont mettre leur céder devant
le juge c'est parfait qui vont mettre
plein ça va faire
mieux que ça et en fait là ils vont
vraiment se regarder dans une
incompréhension de brutal si ils se
touchent le front avec ses doigts ces
dons a gagné oui
[Musique]
insérez un disque vierge pour commencer
ben c'est ce que vient le talonneur de
maître décédé or tengri voilà j'ai
réalisé un rêve de gosse percée dans les
années 2000 les qualités de merde
pourquoi je le tiens de trucs mais
touche pas tous au
[Musique]
premier titre messieurs oui c'est notre
cd de l'autre parce que c'est notre cdc
de référence gelé en revanche ça c'est
grave c'est quoi ça c'est un son tu le
mets tu fais plaît et ça fait que
c'est génial donc là c'est le début de
l'opération je vous dis tout de suite
doucement avec ce que tu vas faire
il à l'aise gros
dégâts donc là en gros on a
officiellement le sondeur ambiance quand
date ce qui va se passer c'est qu'on va
aller tous avec théo pour le clip tout
simplement savoir ce qu'on va faire pour
le clip ok vous êtes chaud
je vais avoir des talkie walkie pauvres
comme ça je vous tiens au courant de
l'opération si elle du danger qui se
rapproche de moi je me dis tu es
j'annule déclarations il faut pas que
j'oublie de céder je mets dans ma poche
secret ninja
je vais tenir un sommet dans ses marques
canon peu de l'accrocher en bref le de
l'accrocher comme ça s'appelle en
collier
mine c'est un génie vient de tout plein
de génie nous anime de
l'éviter au travail oit
mon frère on va communiquer bien ça je
suis très très chaud avec rogers farm en
quoi ouais lucas il est parti vite
et change le mois je vide mes prêches
vous aime pour mes frères je vous aime
je présente le groupe ambiant scandale
sur un truc très années 2000 plutôt du
côté de 113 j'amorce la descente les
gares aux quais
et secouez vous raconter un peu ce que
vous visualisez qu'est ce que vous
voulez voir un clip en fait la teuf
recalage de bottes la teuf
attends je descendais gajac
jaillir
les cas les gars je suis arrivé en bas
donc en gros un club beaucoup de gens
qui dansent énormément de gens qui
énormément de gens qui dansent une
arrivée un peu bling j'imagine un hummer
limousine qui vous dépose quoi ça là que
ces cartes ils vont rentrer en qui sait
les années 2000 un peu dans l'excès bon
chez dans la chute je suis dans
l'arctique pourquoi t'as pas pris de
airpod
j'ai leur céder sous les yeux j'ai leur
céder
en vrai ce que vous me dites ça me fait
un peu penser à jackpot de 1213 bah oui
dans l'esprit en vrai c'est un peu ça
l'idée tu vas à l'entrée de boîte c'est
exactement ainsi sa fin la qualité on va
le tournée actuelle mais le but c'est de
les garder pour qu'on ait vraiment
l'impression que c'était ton isync dhs
en mai 2008 était là
on est en stress l'arrangement ce n'est
pas ce qui se passe je viens de perdre
mon cerveau j'ai perdu mon sac mais le
cdh a été remplacé jours
leur logo derrière comme ça c'était très
et ça se faisait douze ans mais c'est
typique de l'époque ça s comprend pas ça
avec les scandales à placera serait
chaud devant permettre qui fait sourire
vraiment je pourrais pas vous répondre
et les mains prises mais voilà je compte
sur vous je laisse mille de faire ça
ce concours ça ne devait pas de la tarte
grâce à toi
tout beau
bah écoutez les gars on va annoncer ça
dans une semaine on est dans le club
je peux vous dire un truc c'est que rien
ne vous empêche actuellement d'écouté à
ses réelles et le bâtiment par contre on
va le payer donc là non on va faire le
bris de notre clip avec théo way et
après les gars ses six fils se juger
quoi et vous allez voir qu'ils jugent je
suis désolé d'avancé vous allez mon
boulot il se peut que ça leur donne un
avantage
c'est vrai comme si d'aller tirer une
balle dans le pied à la fin de trois
jours de boulot
alors se dit quoi le son est très simple
on est un boys band des pays l'est des
années 2000 magasins coûts du très
simple c'est jamais simple ce ne sera
pas simple mais le briefer simple ok on
a chacun une personnalité différente
mais on voyage en différentes époques
gras ça démontre qu'on a trouvée et
quant on fait cela on réagirait époque à
l'autre et on arrive dans une époque et
nous arrive des bricoles tu vois et au
moment où on va se faire buter aura puis
est hongre change d'époque par exemple
on pourrait arriver au moyen-âge et on
se retrouve sur un pilori comme ça on
pourrait se retrouver au temps des cow
boys et en fait se faire pendre parce
qu'elle est celle où les chronos une
très bonne idée il voulait qu'on fasse
une choré à tout prix je veux danser
dans ce que vous avez conscience que à
l'époque c'était un peu cheap
on est à la recherche de sa ouais ouais
d'accord ensuite pour appuyer sur la
montre future voiture qui volent
évidemment tu ne pourrait dans le futur
aussi et cette fois ci il faut qu'ils
vous qui une petite mascotte aliens qui
passe à côté avec nous les gars c'est
pas du tout simple allez merci merci aux
allées mais c'est beaucoup trop hâte de
tourner le clip 10 ou mon frérot a pas
j'ai tellement hâte
mais ces dames mais dont on est de ce
côté
basque eh ouais
j'ai déjà vécu ce moment une fois et
autant de dire que là j'ai encore plus
impression de la première fois on est
convoqué ou quoi offrir est ce que vous
avez ceci juste là mais un truc
suspicieux déjà on dirait un conseil de
classe et deuxièmement il ya une sacoche
élevé sur le bureau il ya sûrement ses
papiers d'identité de danse qui n'ont
pas si j'ai conduite est rouillée dans
un monologue ici bonheur vous êtes
content de votre sont très contents
c'est un temps sous les très content
nous ça s'est bien passé reste très
heureux si hamid à l'électro je viens de
l'île chrono vient de belgique entre
donc déjà est quelque chose qui vient du
nord jacques brel jack guez j'aurai les
deux mixant les gars je vois on essaie
tous de gagner du temps on a plus la
pression de la part de jacques brel mais
la signature de messieurs occasions
pendant par les noms
vous le savez là on va être jugés par
une personnalité qui a énormément
fonctionner des années 2000 et qui en
plus de ça fonctionne toujours
énormément l'heure actuelle d'assez bon
je suis bien à temps plein évidemment on
présentera chacun notre projet musique à
cette personne on lui dira bombardements
s'inspirer de ça le nom c'est ça et c
est à l'issue de l'ecoute il désignera
le vainqueur selon lui j'ai une pression
de fou actuellement mais je pense qu'il
est temps d'aller chercher monsieur le
juge je me réjouis de faire pipi là
je vais chercher monsieur le juge vous
revient et en plus vous allez kiffer je
vous le dis je mets bien les invités
chicchi
messieurs dames fait du bruit s'il vous
plaît pour
[Musique]
montaner vous très beau de rythme sur
provision est arrivé tu mets une
pression tu sais j'ai intérêt avec vous
il ya la pression parce que sérieux
on n'avait pas besoin de ça en plus
adéquat vous venez on y va les garder au
charbon est ce que vous les décrire
rapidement notre sous notre groupe bien
de l'ess et il s'appelle trail des jets
et qui veut dire les trois doigts la
chanson est intégralement en roumain rom
roumain oui non on n'a rien en vue une
prof de vos mains et la musique
s'appelle my mind la bonne voie à la
hausse du cac voici le céder à toi de
jouer la s'initier derrière
les gens pour être franc le sud du
morceau
l'originalité
de ce qu'on va voir
[Musique]
se félicite à camano une peiné on ne
peut peiner
[Musique]
thierry
johnson
[Musique]
forcément accordé à as
papa
et aux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ménages
ouais ouais
[Applaudissements]
zone évidemment très bonne robe sombre a
touché ici messieurs rim'k va pas se
prononcer il va attendre d'entendre
votre sang à vous avant de dire ce qu'il
a pensé des dessous ce sera alors le
groupe s'appelle ambiant scandale le
sens rappelle offishal et laref bah tu
dois pas connaître du tout je pense que
je n'étais pas renseigné sur ça du tout
mais on est sur une rue très disco funk
début des années 2000 thème recalage de
boîte et je n'en dis pas plus
belles promesses même promesse du coup
ça met une grosse pression parce que
c'est à son je connais très bien ouais
c'est ça le ferait qu'en fait c'est ça
c'est que nous on est foutu en fait
belle prise de risque l'essentiel c'est
de participer
[Musique]
si proche le front avec ses doigts c'est
mon à gagner
c'est ça c'est pas moi c'est pas très
années 2000
jusqu'à la fin vous êtes bon moment là
vous avez plus de stress franchement ça
nous a détendu a d'un coup merci bout
[Musique]
pression' et survêt de l'or surtout les
colis et ses ambiances tu connais déjà
les deux bras croisés tu connais le pas
bon ce sont même les tontons temps
champions comme le sac sensible
au delà
[Musique]
si ce sont les mots le second
michal dons qu'ils imitent bon somme
actionnariat rien de fictif ailleurs
dehors aujourd'hui je suis dedans je
veux commune et je fais le petit pas de
danse j'étais dehors et maintenant je
suis dedans cheveux gominés je fais le
petit pas de penser
ça n'a rien à voir les bazars n'avoir
mais c'était le cas pour moi et je tiens
juste à dire que bon sens même les
tontons danse c'était vraiment pas prévu
du tout et c'est une monsieur doyer
elano t on à la tentative je tenais à y
aller l'idée de toi y en a trop fait et
nous tous dans le sens il est axé sur
l'exercice
rim car la redite déjà je vais dire à
mon avis sur les deux morceaux ont déjà
atteint une taille vraiment que vous
m'avez parlé de roumanie c deja est bon
de faire une michael youn avec fatal
bazooka
un truc chelou et finalement pas super
super étonné vraiment dans le bon sens
parce qu'une [ __ ] de musicalité
franchement les mélodies es tu pour être
franc du même que sans au moins est
vraiment super titre vraiment bravo les
gars
bon les gars comment vous dire ça
avant les années 2000 autre morceau
serait jamais sortie
les précieuses fort
franchement vraiment pareil je suis
étonné dans le bon sens parce que c'est
pas un exercice facile il faut se
remettre dedans dans l'état d'esprit de
l'époque et puis des sonorités c'est pas
les mêmes et l'effort que vous avez fait
c'est extraordinaire franchement y'a un
gros gros gros taft voit vraiment né
gravant dans la thématique est
franchement bravo les gars
bon maintenant je vais donner le verdict
mais vraiment ça joue vraiment très très
très très peu de choses
[Musique]
on va choisir combien scandale office
[Applaudissements]
je suis trop content d'eux
d'avoir perdu
pas de noms mais l'expérience était ouf
ont cessé d sacré piège et tous tes
incroyable on a eu le vote de juridica
vous remporter cette première épreuve
mais ensuite il y aura le vote du public
qui va se faire via la vente des
physiques qui n'est pas à lancer encore
ne montez pas bon dans cette vidéo la
sorte la suite pour nous actuellement
c'est détourner les clips est ce que
vous allez faire des clips un peu
justement mode 113 et ou en cloud comme
ça j'ai repéré un pool ou des
jeans de grand frère on va aller tourner
ça on se retrouve après dans quelques
semaines et j'aurai des petites
surprises pour vous encore oui lors des
bonnes des bonnes des bonnes que
ces
jurés de nouvelle bonne surprise pour
vous et ça mettra la fin de cette vidéo
rim k merci d'être venus aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup
merci à vous pour l'accueil merci à vous
pour le respect de la musique que vous
avez mis parce que c'est du très bon son
il faut dire la vérité et puis le petit
hommage aux années 2000 113 sézanne a
touché plein coeur plein coeur
franchement bravo
ea dans trois semaines
[Musique]
bon les clips sorte dans quatre jours en
même temps que les clips sorte les
singles en version physique comme les
années 2000 c'est à dire il ya le sont
plus la version instrumentale y aura un
gagnant y aura un son favori et cette
année c'est pas le son qui va le plus
faire de vues sur youtube où son qui va
le plus primé sur les plateformes ça va
être comme dans les années 2000 ça va
être le son qui s'est le plus vendu en
physique déjà j'ai les physiques
l'actuellement donc je peux vous donner
le premier exemplaire de votre physique
et pareil pour vous les gars
est ce que vous êtes prêt
[Musique]
payant
les gars c'est ouf c'est chaud ça génère
la nostalgie je te jure j'imagine le
maître en voiture comme moi je dis mais
c'est trop court sachez qu'au moment où
on se parle les cds sont pas encore en
vente ils seront en vente dans quatre
jours au moment où les clips seront mis
en ligne et y aura sur le site un
compteur en direct de qui a vendu
combien de disques je précise un truc
aussi on en a parlé en début de vidéo
mais j'en reparle maintenant tous les
bénéfices liés à la vente de ses singles
seront reversés au secours populaire
on a fait ça a clairement pour jouer le
côté rp des années 2000 à fond si en
plus on peut régaler une association qui
aide les gens franchement ça tue le fou
j'ai une dernière surprise pour vous ça
n'en finit pas on a fait oui certes des
versions physiques mais ils sont en
vente sur un site web pas très années
2000 c'est pour cette raison que je me
suis démené pour que ce soit en vente
dans un endroit physique messieurs il y
aura à compter du 16 novembre nos cd
dans tous les magasins lidl de france
n'est
pas médecin en rayons comme ça machin on
voulait faire comme s'il y avait des
fois dans les années 2000 c'est y avait
des petits stands en carton un peu cheap
vous pouvez acheter des cd de ses vers
la caisse et où j'ai ici le truc qu'il y
aura dans tous les leaders
maintenant pour la gestuelle ont fait un
don fait à dion fait à deux tu es prêt
[Applaudissements]
ce sera donc dans tous les magasins lidl
de france pendant 30 jours à partir du
16 tous les bénéfices liés à la vente
des cd dans les magasins lidl seront eux
aussi reversés au secours populaire
pendant les 30 jours avant que les cds
n'existe plus qu'on ne fera plus jamais
fabriqué c'est vraiment 30 jours vous
pourrez suivre du coup les ventes en
direct sur le site web well on verrait
l'évolution des ventes de chaque groupe
en temps réel ça va durer trente jours
et à la fin des trente jours on aura
déjà le grand gagnant est aussi et
surtout on saura combien on a récolté de
fonds pour le secours populaire donc
voilà je vous tiendrai au courant de ça
évidemment je connais créé là dessus et
puis fin de l'histoire les gars je vous
le dis ça me fait quelque chose de ce
soit fini là ce tournage dans dix ans on
fait un truc mais sur les musiques des
années 2015 j'en fais pll qu'on sera
vraiment vieux aussi chantant les 1 0
moi je serais mort ouverture du site
dans quatre jours présence décédé dans
quatre journaux tout est l'idole donc le
16 novembre on espère que les clips vous
plairont j'ai hâte de voir le vote je
pense qu'on fera peut-être un petit live
tweet pour réagir chacun occupe de
l'autre et je suis très content parce
que globalement on a vraiment de trucs
très différents et c'est ce qu'on
s'était dit j'en voulais vraiment pas
que ça se ressemble et on a vraiment
deux grands axes dès 2010 pour ça bravo
à vous les amis vous avez tous accompli
votre mission à merveille et je pense
que le thème est respectée
on se trouve dans quatre jours pour les
clips sur la chaîne youtube merci le
motive merci à tous qu'ils merci tall
dia merci masqué merci chrono musique
merci mille n'hésitez pas suffisamment
comme ça personne pour les acheter
soleil là
[Musique]